i'm nancy bass and i'm proud to be one
of the owners of the strand you might
think that i don't look old enough to
own this but i'm standing on the
shoulders of my grandfather and father
who have walked
the floors of the strand since 1927.
we are thrilled to have c-span and its
inspirational founder brian lamb with us
and we believe that now that the
political conventions are over america
can get down to the truly bipartisan
business
of reading and loving great books
i hope that you are enjoying the program
as much as i am and before i introduce
art spiegelman let me give you a brief
update on what is happening at the
strand
first
our wonderful customers some of whom are
part of families that have been coming
to the strand for generations
have successfully
worn down my dad and he's agreed to a
host of what i call 20th century
innovations
we now have books available online
and an elevator linking four floors of
books together
i grew up with customers pleading
for air conditioning
well it's here now
and who knows someday we may even serve
coffee
today art spiegelman honors us by
launching his masterful new creation in
the shadow of no towers
america has waited eight years for this
book
art along with his family lives and
works downtown near ground zero
he gives a powerful account of his 9 11
experiences and the frustrations he
feels about how government
responded to the tragedy
his groundbreaking book mouse
won a pulitzer prize
this is a favorite amongst our customers
in fact
more copies have been sold here than
from any single bookstore
not surprisingly art has a childhood
fascination with comics beginning with
mad magazine
as a teenager he was drawing for his
weekly paper in rigo park queens
and publishing his own magazine
he had a lazy eye that made it difficult
to see in three dimensions
so according to art cartoons really did
seem real to him
then he went to work out of all places
tops bubble gum company off and on for
20 years we have art to thank for
garbage pail kids
and wacky packs
in 1980 he and his wife founded the
acclaimed and influential magazine of
avant-garde
comics and graphics called raw
he's also a staff writer and illustrator
for the new yorker
little is it known that art's parents
really wanted him to become a dentist
so we are overjoyed that you're here
with us
and that you are not outperforming root
canals
here's art spiegelman
[Applause]
thanks for having me this is a store
i've come to for generations and
brian's program is something i put on
whenever npr goes through car talk or a
slow patch i listen to
uh
these uh weekend book shows as my radio
um
i didn't have a chance to really prepare
uh
a talk for you and didn't want to quite
read so i'm going to just free associate
the reason that uh i didn't prepare
anything specifically is i spent the
last few days either on protest marches
or with a press pass from the new yorker
on the floor of the convention and i'm
trying to make a strip in about two or
three days about it
so as soon as i leave here i get to go
back to try to do that
um
this book was never meant to be it was
never meant to be a book
it grew out of um
a vow made on september 11th after i uh
ran out of the rubble with uh my
daughter who had just started stuyvesant
and my wife was the art editor of the
new yorker um and turned back on to
canal street and among all these uh
memento mori uh pledges the kind of
things you do on new year's eve
there was a kind of uh rush of affection
for my city which was one uh
very specific response that even
surprised me
i can't be sure if i'm a patriot for
america but i know i pledge allegiance
to the dark blue zone of lower manhattan
and
among the pledges i made was you know
schmuck you really should have made more
comics because i really felt we were
going to die that morning
and
the problem with comics is you have to
feel like you're going to live forever
to do them it's a very slow process and
like a farmer paid to not grow wheat
i uh found that i could uh just either
draw or write and do far better for
myself in terms of esteem and
ease of work for a basically lazy person
who overcompensates for his laziness by
uh avoiding comics
and which are somehow in general one is
penalized for being able to somewhat
right and somewhat draw until maybe very
recently where
while the world is doing terribly comics
as graphic novels seem to be doing very
well
it makes me wish that i spent the last
30 years fighting for world peace rather
than for comics as literature
um
but the
book was
a result of kind of coming out of
an extended state of shock that left me
stuck in september 11th and 12th for at
least six months
and
after that i began to just take my
whatever little notes i had gathered to
see what i wanted to do and what i
really wanted to do at first was um
report on what
i subjectively saw felt and understood
of that morning where i was receiving it
unmediated and
have that in opposition to what was
coming to me from uh
my television set which is where the
rest of the planet
was actually better informed about
september 11th than uh i at about 10 in
the morning when i was still
stuck in the uh
bowels of stuyvesant high school at
ground zero um what happened that
morning was francoise and i lived on
um near the corner of canal street came
out of our place to vote early in the
morning saw a plane overhead saw it
crash into a building and then uh fairly
quickly decided we better go down and
get our daughter out of the high school
stuyvesant that she just started
attending
a few days before because it seemed like
well gee it could fall over and land on
the school and then we spent the next
hour or so trying to find our daughter
among the 3 000 students while we were
in the building the uh
stuyvesant shook and all of its lights
went out when the first tower fell but
we couldn't see that and in the midst of
the panic i went running around the
building
trying to find naja who only became
genuinely fearful of what she'd been
seeing right out of her window in the
library of the school uh when she saw me
because then it was obviously real and
not an hallucination
um
and we got out of the school a few
minutes before the rest of the school
was finally evacuated and uh when we had
gotten to the west side highway the
second tower fell
and unlike what it looked like on
television which was just this large
toxic cloud that appeared where the
tower had been there was a moment that
uh
basically
had this 110 story high tower turning
into the glowing bones of itself just uh
white yellow orange incandescent bones
of a tower
uh above us that seemed to be there
forever before it began to like fall in
on itself and be replaced by that white
cloud and that was some kind of uh
either the largest blue screen effect
i've ever seen on in the world or
a
moment
out of time and i began to try to paint
that and one of the reasons i became a
cartoonist is because i can't paint very
well and i just couldn't get it and
eventually i found that working on a
computer i was able to make something
that's the title page picture of those
towers it looks quite accurate to me and
my wife francoise and my daughter nadja
as more like a photograph rather than a
drawing of what that actually looked
like at the moment it fell and that
image informs the ten plates that make
up the core of this book the those
glowing towers that exist somehow out of
time and were what i saw as i point out
in the first page
those crumbling towers burned their way
into every brain but i live on the
outskirts of ground zero and first saw
it all live unmediated
maybe it's just a question of scale even
on a large tv the towers aren't much
bigger than say dan rather's head logos
on the other hand look enormous on
television it's a medium almost as well
suited as comics for dealing in
abstraction
um so the original plan of drawing what
i saw as opposed to what was on the tv
became hijacked by what started coming
at me on the tv by
um
a government that seemed to be turning
it into a war recruiting poster
uh
and
i
couldn't even enjoy my trauma in peace
the what i needed was time to assimilate
that uh intense morning that lasted for
weeks
and it became impossible when the
hijacking itself was seemed to be
hijacked
right around the corner from here
basically is union square and for a long
time
no for about five days union square was
the bottom of manhattan
it was where everybody gathered from the
rest of the city where police barriers
wouldn't let you go below unless you had
a a pass i finally felt like i lived in
a gated community i could get down to
canal street
but if i wanted somebody to come visit i
had to go up and bring them down with me
or a babysitter or anything like that
and when i get to union square there was
a moment where i was living not just
near ground zero but in year zero it
wasn't clear from all the people that
were there among the shrines the missing
posters uh
and the like that what this would
inevitably lead to was war uh certainly
not a war in iraq that was beyond most
people's imaginings outside of uh
um
a cabal but the
original um
feeling of that place was okay
civilization as we knew it has to be
reassessed and we have to figure out
what comes next uh out of all of the
writings that happened immediately after
september 11th there's an issue of the
new yorker that i did the cover for that
came out about five or six days after
the event which was my black on black uh
ghosts of these towers that come up like
an after image
of which the cover of the new book is
kind of a quotation of that cover
although this black is a lot lighter
than the black those on the new yorker
there's many blacks as ed reinhardt
taught us and the um
this sort of is made to be seen right
away the cover of the new yorker was one
where you couldn't see the silhouette of
the towers right away just sort of come
at you as it sat on your coffee table
sometimes three days later the phantom
limb after image of that tower came up
but in that same issue of the new yorker
there was a piece by susan sontag and it
was a magnet for all of the outrage that
uh
was directed against
a
measured response to what had happened
it was made possible for her by the
luxury of being overseas when the
attack happened and yet had it been said
not five or six days after the attack
but two weeks after people could have
heard it instead it was just the
hectoring tone of somebody saying
something in politics at a funeral
you know uh that kept uh her insistence
that uh this was cause for reassessment
to figure out what we've done that kind
of allowed uh an al-qaeda to grow and
flourish uh as opposed to just consider
it a um
a war in some traditional old-fashioned
sense
um
it's her take is one that i ended up
certainly subscribing to and found
myself more and more drawn into
having to deal with
directly political issues i hate
political cartoons they have a short
life
uh it's kind of like a shelf life like
yogurts you know like uh nothing that
can possibly last a picture of an an
angry picture of a president like after
a few years maybe thank god but after
some few years it's just footnotes and
history books and for a long time i've
been living with the notion that
one could approach comics as one
approaches literature with one uh corner
of an eyeball out for posterity
um
the morning of september 11th when i was
saying gee i should draw more comics
i was doing them provisionally it took
me a few months to get started and when
i was doing them i really had no
notion of making any kind of book out of
this i was just figuring while i was
waiting for the world to end and i would
make a page while waiting and then oh
the world didn't end i could make
another and uh they were appearing
primarily in uh what was quaintly called
old europe a coalition of the willing uh
that included uh french magazine desigt
a german newspaper was the commissioning
paper in an italian magazine in uh
holland in belgium um
and here it appeared in the foreword
where i explained to my editor that uh
these didn't exactly have to do with
being jewish per se the forward being a
final socialist jewish weekly and i was
given the right of returns okay you're
jewish so it was allowed to run there
even though the subject matter wasn't
overtly and specifically about being
jewish except for the fact that it
probably does reduce down to being a
giant ayaahi and they were like monthly
journal pages
uh there were a condensation of what i
had experienced that month and it was
only by the time i'd hit the sixth or
seventh page that i began to slow down
enough uh to say well maybe the world
will last long enough for me to make a
book but a book uh presumes posterity
and i wasn't sure that there could be
such a thing so it's a very provisional
book
uh the pages originally were broadsheet
size like usa today size and maybe
because of that
working in that size that's no longer
the luxury afforded to most cartoonists
and working without an editor because it
all started by me talking to the editor
of the site and complaining about being
edited i see it the normal process of
editing as something very similar to
censorship
and
he said it's okay i'll give you a no
editors clause and as i began doing
these large broad sheets i found myself
uh channeling the old comic strip
characters by the cartoonists who are
making these things as broad sheets in
the first days of the sunday comics
which were born right next to ground
zero on newspaper row
and i found myself drawing myself and my
wife francoise not as me and her
quarreling but as maggie and jiggs i
found that a lot of this was too unreal
for me to take uh as a real given
reality and uh started channeling little
nemo in slumber land and
what um i realized about these strips
which were the only things that gave me
solace after september 11th w h auden
was not doing it for me i couldn't
concentrate on the poem so i just
remembered that line about uh we must
all love one another or die and found i
was getting that same message from
comics where it's easier for me to
understand that language and part of
what made those old comics so poignant
for me
was that they were ephemeral they were
made like a dance they weren't made like
a painting for posterity they were made
to wrap fish 24 hours later they were
part of a news cycle and the working
steps who made them put their entire
personalities in them and their entire
talent which on some
in some cases like windsor mckay's was
as great as anybody working in the
so-called high arts but seeing them is
like eavesdropping on a moment long gone
that one has no right to see
and
their very ephemeralness
ephemerality ephemera their quality of
being ephemeral um
uh made them seem to me
somehow now seeing them again as
timeless as say towers that are built to
last forever that also proved to be
ephemeral and
civilizations and experiments and styles
of government that also are ultimately
ephemeral and so there was a not only
timeless moment for me when these towers
fell and those towers somehow provide
the spine from which all of the other
moments that i'm reporting on jut out on
these pages but also a
feeling of disorientation that allowed
the past to be my future like looking
toward these old ephemeral comics gave
me courage to go and make new ones and
as a result this really strange book
object
is sort of divided into two towers one
being the ten pages the ten plates i
made and they're full scale and one
being uh
plates from the early part of the
century uh the comics that ultimately
grew out of being footnotes of me
explaining to people who had never seen
happy hooligan who he was but finding
that
the pages i used looked like they could
have been drawn yesterday and be more
pointed as political cartoons than most
of what's allowed to appear in a very
docile american press so happy hooligan
was this pre
chaplin s hapless bum with a tin can on
his head as a hat
and the example i found was abdullah
again the arab clown has a turban on
around his uh tin can hat and is a an
arab clown and dark face uh in a circus
riding a camel he has a rifle over his
shoulder he keeps turning to waves to
his nephews every time he turns he
clobbers the uh camel inadvertently with
his rifle
eventually the camel gets rightly ticked
off
lifts him up and kicks him into a tower
of acrobats that tumble
so
since i didn't have any specific agenda
except to sort of vaguely introduce what
this project was maybe i should like let
us take questions
love to
i want to ask you about we i read this
to the audience earlier
uh the ostrich party
you have that in your book
rampaging republican elephants
dim-witted democratic donkeys no wonder
real americans don't bother to vote the
two-party animals are both 19th century
dinosaurs interested only in their own
survival not ours we need a third party
that actually represents us a new and
revolutionary ostrich party is that your
philosophy no it was back when i did
that page this is the nature of ephemera
certain pages come back into being
present other ones are comments on the
moment and may indeed have reason i
still basically believe that our way of
voting is nuts ranging from the
electoral college to the big money
that's involved in mounting these
elections to the fact that we don't have
room for multiple rounds of elections
make this a very distorted system and
yet right now i'd be glad to donate that
particular panel to nader uh and let him
use it for his recruit recruiting
in the current structure to vote for the
ostrich party is uh really to condemn
yourself to not having a vote we are
left with a not only a polarized
electorate but a polarized set of
choices that are very urgent so you're
going to vote in november um absolutely
uh as always with a nose clip on um and
basically i think this is probably the
most urgent election i've ever lived
through and i not only didn't want to
draw political cartoons when i was doing
these pages but found myself dragooned
into it but um i'm not interested in
politics i i've grown up like most
americans thinking of politics as
optional the way you might be interested
in the knicks or something you could be
interested in democrats and republicans
and i was not that interested in either
but more and more i'm stuck with that
stupid t-shirt of all all politics is
personal um
at this point one has no exit strategy
short of appealing to these uh two
parties to find a way out of the most
dangerous heart of the situation we're
in toward at least a somewhat less
dangerous situation
and and basically as a result the way
i've positioned myself and think about
it now having come out of uh for three
three days because i couldn't stand it
one day on the republican floor at
madison square garden is i found what i
was meeting there reptilian cold-blooded
and reptilian and as a result i don't
hold out that much personal hope uh that
kerry will meet my needs but just out of
class interest meaning biological class
interest i would like to see
a mammal in the white house and
in
[Applause]
better times
in better times i would like to find a
member of my own species
one one of the reasons we do these
programs is to let people from around
the country
react to what they're hearing here in
new york city among them i'm sure
they'll have your reaction i want to
make sure that people here in the
audience that have something they want
to say or comment feel free to walk to
the microphone plus we have the numbers
on the screen for art spiegelman those
who support president bush you can see
the number those who support senator
kerry and those that consider themselves
in a third party or not going to vote at
all would let me go back to you though
if there's nobody at the microphone uh
we'll take a call
are you part of the problem though if
you say you've never been interested in
politics half america doesn't vote is
that i was part of the problem i did
vote and it's not like i was totally
disinterested i actually know more about
politics than i do about the knicks but
i am not uh
um
as
f i haven't i hadn't been as focused on
this before september 11th i found
myself uh doing images for the new
yorker that definitely had uh political
content certainly during the amadou
diallo uh
mess in new york i did a picture that
got my mayor very angry um and i did
stuff about uh the clinton and monica uh
event but i didn't find that that was
the general focus for me that like i
remained narcissistically uninvolved and
if anything i guess i would like to make
sure i can't believe that anybody
watching c-span is part of the problem
of the 100 million people that aren't
registered though so i won't go into
that we are
we are here at the strand on this sunday
afternoon live all afternoon long taking
your calls talking to different people
richard brookheiser harold evans will
join us at the top of the hour and a
gentleman back here has a comment please
give your name
hi my name is scott rosenbaum uh
comics and sequential art are a way of
telling a story and it definitely has
something to do with the passage of time
and you did that masterfully in mouse
i'm curious as to
know whether your style of storytelling
has changed when you're trying to
portray a moment as you described as
being out of time
existing out of time thank you and tell
us first what mouse is for those who
have not read it uh mouse is uh what's
now called a graphic novel when when i
did it was just a comic book that needed
a bookmark um
and what i wanted to do is um tell the
story of my parents who had survived
auschwitz through the deposition i took
over a period of years with my father
who had been uh
in auschwitz and told the story of my
life with my father in the then present
and uh in the course of making that i
found that the characters all needed to
have masks on so i had mouse masks for
the jews cat masks for the uh
nazis and um dog masks for the gis and
so on um
this is a very different work i know
that it's being billed as uh his first
graphic novel since mao's i don't even
know that this is a graphic novel it's a
very fat comic book it's got very few
pages in it it's on cardboard pages uh
next one i think i'm going to do on
stone because then i only have to do two
pages and i can
kind of carry them around like that but
um
essentially the reason for the cardboard
pages is i needed i did these as very
large sheets nobody would publish a book
this size and by doing them as a
children's board book there's no gutter
and i could have these strange layouts
uh fill up the scale that they needed to
have to deal with these 110 story powers
to answer the question about time
standing still essentially what i found
myself doing was constantly referring
back to this
image by the repetition of the image
forcing you into that timeless moment
and then allowing shards of other
thoughts to come into it to be flashes
of uh momentary anecdote and time but
ultimately this thing is like a the
tower is like a um
the memento mori that keeps coming back
and what i needed to make on these pages
specifically returned me back to the
kind of comics i was making before mouse
that were much more structural it's a
good word to use in context of talking
about these two towers but ultimately
um
in mouse it was my job to get out of the
damn story's way and that meant anything
formal that was interesting to me had to
be sublimated it's there but it's not to
be seen unless somebody's actually
staring at it as a comic scholar it's
just meant to be absorbed eventually you
forget you're reading a comic i suspect
and you forget that there are cat and
mouse heads on these people here for
example by having a page structured
so that
um
when you first approach it you see these
two towers on this large image and if
you start reading from left to right and
get over to that top of that tower over
there you don't know whether to read
down or go to that tower or go here and
essentially the dislocation that you
feel with the pages you're trying to
find your orientation is uh the
dislocation that i felt on september
11th let's say in the middle there you
have a
picture of dan rather arch that you've
drawn it says maybe it's just a question
of scale even on a large tv the towers
aren't much bigger than say dan rather's
head
uh any reason for that well yeah um
essentially
most of the information that we all get
the way we're all plugged in is through
the same cameras and i can't be sure
that there's a war in iraq because it
could be some kind of philip k dick
movie that's being projected outward to
me i am sure the towers fell
uh you can't be because i could be part
of the philip k dick movie on television
for you watching but um but essentially
it was a matter of trying to sort out
what i experienced and what uh was
coming at me otherwise let me grab a
call from san mateo california for art
spiegelman go ahead please you're on the
air
yes art um
your your depiction here seems to be
pretty much one-sided um and and very
very
um
very anti-bush okay
um
that's true which is true which is true
um
is there any way of getting any kind of
objective um sense
to
uh your point of view
i mean yes what if there was more of a
left-wing press prominent in america one
could triangulate
uh in other words right now the
so-called objective point of view seems
to be represented by anything that's to
the left of fox which still leaves us
very very far away from something to
triangulate from
and i don't think it's my job to do that
one more time one thing that was
interesting to me on the floor is in
order to not be ashamed when i was at
the republican convention on the third
day i wore my protest t-shirt that i'd
worn on sunday which was a handmade
shirt that said pray for a secular
future
um
and
at that point um i was sitting in the
bleachers somewhere and a guard pulled
me out to read it he read it i suspect
he didn't understand the word secular so
he let me back in and then i tried to go
down and exchange my bleachers pass for
a floor pass to get closer to where the
action was and at that desk i was turned
away by a secret service person who did
know the word secular and said takes a
minute to get that one and they said
you're supposed to be a journalist
meaning i couldn't go down on the floor
with that message on
and meanwhile other journalists were
going on the floor with bush cheney pins
what does that tell you about
objectivity monroe louisiana you're next
please go ahead for art spiegelman
first let me say
thank you for smoking i thought that had
been outlawed in your town
it was and bloomberg's police are now
free to have a large scooter procession
to meet me at the door
and second from your lips to god's ear
that we give a pink flip to the reptile
who is in the white house
okay i'm with you let's go to the
audience here do you have a question
please and give us your name
hi my name is kate and um i'm wondering
if you saw the most recent michael moore
film
and what your views were on that and
also
right yes
and also uh any words on chomsky if you
want to bring that into the discussion
okay um great you know one thing when i
was talking about this triangulation uh
between fox and something else
interestingly enough the triangulation
does exist with a book by chomsky that
can get to be a bestseller with a lot of
uh journalism being put into book form
now uh that in some ways for a long time
the fourth estate sort of fell asleep
and became to my eyes uh fifth column it
wasn't there for us and as a result the
real information that one needed that
should have been part of the daily press
and part of the magazine press tended
very often to end up in hard covers and
uh
that means that those who can read and
are willing to read can actually get a
larger picture of the landscape we're
living in unfortunately that's not
the bulk of the electorate that does get
its news through quick flashes as a
result michael moore's film seems to
have been useful to find people who
weren't getting that same information by
trolling the internet for uh more
sophisticated news sources for me there
was relatively little surprising in uh
michael moore's films except the footage
of uh people pelting uh when he was
trying to get to the white house right
after his election that wasn't stuff i
saw on television and the uh black
caucus's tragic uh attempt to get a
recount of votes in 2000 also wasn't
widely seen except in that movie i'm
grateful for michael moore he's much
more focused a human than i am um my
work does have a political dimension but
in this particular case it's not as
focused i tried to do a lot of things at
once uh in each of these monthly journal
reports that made up the no towers
plates but uh what michael moore does is
he has a kind of class analysis or at
least a class hatred that keeps him very
focused and it means that everything's
coming from somewhere i was very
impatient with that woman that became
the star of the second half of this film
because she's
wrapped up in some kind of provincial
flag waving uh taking solace in uh
a in a lot of slogans and uh religions
and then finally wakes up when her son
is affected and by his sympathy for her
he was able to pull out a narrative that
was well worth having and so i'm
grateful for it i found myself in a way
reduced to being sort of a local michael
moore uh when the strip was appearing in
europe in that michael moore's uh
reception as you know in in uh cheesy
surrender monkey country was uh really
awesome and uh it was a ratification
that not all americans are uh gop
uh republicans and i think that although
it wasn't my intention my strip gave uh
some solace to europeans who are very
confused by america's foreign policy
right now little rock arkansas go ahead
please you're on with art spiegelman
good afternoon gentlemen um i wanted uh
to make two points if i could one is
address to
nancy bass if she's around
i noticed that on their table
of bestsellers there were two notable
uh omissions
that is of course uh unfit for command
and uh a soldier's life by general
franks
and to mr spiegelman and to the audience
that's there
um
the contempt
that you feel towards
what you call the religious right
and the fact that we out here are stupid
and don't breathe stupid but i do have
contempt for the lord
your arrogance your your arrogance is
really beyond belief as was mr bello who
said he's glad he was in the middle of a
bunch of evangelicals well he doesn't
know any evangelicals if you knew some i
mean who is this religious right anyway
it's people i've grown up with all my
life
and uh well i saw an interesting piece
in the times about how the event
evangelicals aren't even as monolithic
as they've been presented uh in the
press either today or yesterday's
op-ed
uh column of the times and that's
probably true i know that i don't know
if those two books are here but i know
there was only when i was stuck in an
airport in mississippi that i saw the
left behind books i've never seen them
in my book stores in new york um this is
the timothy lahaye books uh let me ask
are you still there caller allegheny
except in an airplane and i would bet
you that that's true of most of the live
people i said i guess they're alive
they're certainly not thinking
who are sitting in the audience
uh thank you very much for listening as
a person who is a uniter not a divider
we can be sure that bush didn't succeed
at least in that mission right
let me ask you a question that keeps
coming up uh based on what you're saying
and what we saw when we covered last
sunday's
demonstration out uh there was a big
huge fox sign out in front of the
building and as people came by they said
some very strong four-letter word things
about fox news
uh
and i know the audience is very much
unhappy with fox news why is it a town
that is so liberal
with all the publishing industries and
all the media and everything it gets so
upset about one company that has
somewhere between two and three million
viewers every night
out of 294 million why is it you get
well it sounds like all of the biggest
ratings for the convention coverage
certainly were fox news recently but six
million people watched them yeah 294
million why is it you get so
basically the marching orders that come
from there get repeated the stories that
get distorted on fox news get
disseminated further than just being uh
left to being a provincial
news station by the rest of a media that
i'm also unhappy with you know like it's
been reported incorrectly that i left uh
the new yorker in protest i've seen that
uh a number of times it was a distortion
of something i'd said in an italian
magazine that got repeated here to have
left the new yorker would be just like
beating your wife because you're angry
at george bush you know like uh
essentially this wasn't the enemy ever
on the other hand even the new yorker uh
at a certain moment took on the
conventional wisdom and did something
unheard of which is in his talk section
the editor chose to endorse uh the war
as a reluctant talk um and it took a
long time for things like to see more
hirsch pieces to appear that gave me
confidence in my magazine again and i
found that in general i was just in a
kind of internal exile where when i
would look at uh news sources coming
from france coming from england i was
getting a much bigger picture than what
i was getting from any place in america
and what i believe fox has done is not
so much uh become the central and only
loudspeaker but it seems to be the place
from which a lot of news emanates so
that the rest of the news takes what's
said on fox as if it were a fact resida
california for art spiegelman he'll be
with us for another 10 15 minutes go
ahead please okay uh first of all
i've been actually waiting a couple of
decades to let mr spiegelman know that
you know what uh
thank you very much for the garbage pail
kids cars i'll tell you right now that
was the best idea and i think that's
actually what gives you the credibility
as a writer you know or as a cartoonist
you know from one animator to another
anyways uh getting straight to my point
it's not really a question i was just a
couple of uh
statements here basically um
i believe that uh the way you depict
certain points
for america it's basically the proper
way to be done
i think people will listen more
and um
also i think you know
as uh america has been uniting after
9 911 and all that i think
i think you know we should all just kind
of open our minds a bit more and just
kind of like you know
let it all go like you know especially
the people who were demonstrating
outside the republican convention i i
think that's that's that's a bit of
maturity you know even for people with
that kind of belief because it's like
we're not getting anything done right
and uh one more thing is if so if you
haven't received the pulitzer prize yet
i think i think you're you're on the
road for that thanks carla when did you
receive your poulter in 1992 it was a
special pulitzer's like the special
olympics it was a separate
category um
to respond to what this last caller said
i just say that uh yes it's true that
words and pictures can plug in in a way
that uh print alone can't and pictures
that stand still the way they do in
comics might be more useful in terms of
allowing reflection than the steady
parade of stuff that happens on tv the
only thing i can't really agree with is
that the protesters were immature
there's no other way to have a dialogue
than to insist on having the side that
tends to be muzzled and muffled to come
out and indicate its displeasure it
should be seen as part of an ongoing
process what scared me was that for a
full year the year that this book uh
documents is really from 2002 to 2003 it
ran from september 11th to september
11th during that year there wasn't any
dissent the papers were filled with uh
things that indicated a kind of fearful
response to being accused of being
unpatriotic as soon as the presidential
election season and somehow began
revving up which was september 2003
all of a sudden a vigorous debate became
part of what was possible and necessary
just if nothing else uh to show that we
had a democracy and what i'm afraid of
is that that can go back to sleep again
i was beginning to feel like i could
avoid politics because finally the
newspapers were awake we were beginning
to track down where abu ghraib uh was
sourced what brought that about and then
all of a sudden the press went into a
binge of ronald reagan celebrating there
was like a northeast right to unplug
every electronic device in my house
for a full week the abu ghraib story
disappeared and only now is it even
beginning to inch back into public
consciousness coming up in about 20
minutes we'll have richard burkhauser
and harold evans then an hour later jon
fund and amy goodman and our stop here
at the strand bookstore we go to a lady
in the audience your name please hello
my name is arlene and i wanted to tell
people when i speak i speak as an
american
and i have been working for three years
as a clinical social worker with many
many 9-1-1 family members
even in this room my husband and i have
called up repeatedly
we did our homework we went into every
single newspaper and found articles and
we even told on c-span where conspiracy
nuts
i brought with me
june 1st 2001 to me is one of the most
important days in american history
that the joint chiefs of staff changed
the directive from
1997 that said
only in a hijacking commanders are
stripped of the responsibility to act
that norad was forbidden to proceed when
they got the phone call at 8 13 that
there were four planes being hijacked
that same day in norad's magazine they
showed a picture a bin laden in the
middle with four planes so when they
said they could not imagine any planes
being hijacked and people were screaming
in new york city that day before the
towers went down what happened to our
air force we find out
that they had norad had a command center
right outside atlantic city they were
waiting for hours to proceed and they
were told not to so when we're concerned
about asking the questions like you say
in an open debate as soon as we start
asking these questions the family
members we're told shut up the american
government will go crumbling down
thank you
i found myself on september 12th 13th
and 14th while sort of somehow
channeling that new yorker cover and uh
channeling my tv set and the web that i
was getting more and more into things
that would leave me in grassy knoll land
for the next few years and i ended up
having to uh protect myself from it by
deciding it wasn't necessary for me to
figure out uh whether or not
uh there was a conspiracy that led to uh
the
towers uh attack
it was enough to see how that attack was
instrumentalized and stay therefore on
grounds where that just wasn't the most
urgent aspect of what was happening for
me and that uh
whoever did this with whatever knowledge
and uh
um
possible
ways of averting it that had been
ignored some of which came out in the
911 commission some of which as you
point out haven't been allowed to come
out what was more important in the short
term and
like i said for months and months i felt
i was living in the short term
uh
i believe it's more important to see how
that thing was being used we were a
united nation when if you'll forgive the
phrase out in parts of the country that
don't like that we were a united country
uh
for a while and
i was even amazed at how new york was
embraced as part of america uh after
after 9 11 and yet um
that that moment was squandered we found
ourselves not only divided in america
but with a world that's divided against
us as well this book uh your book in the
shot of no tires uh the price here at uh
strand is 14.95 the list price is 19.95
isn't that amazing it is amazing i'm
impressed yeah now is this out now
available for people official pub date
is uh september 7th but my friends tell
me they've been seeing it in stores all
over all right december 7th september
september i'm sorry september 7th so in
the next couple in fact one of the
questions i was asked in an interview
recently from someone in iowa for uh for
a newspaper was well you say that bush
is exploiting september 11th do you
think you are by coming out with this
book and my immediate snarled response
was i was here and he wasn't here until
the 14th of september when all he did
was snarl up traffic further um
essentially this was based on visceral
responses that didn't really even have
exactly a political agenda it didn't
start out being that this picture that
caused a lot of trouble for me which was
uh in the second of my pages that had
bin laden on one side and bush on the
other as i try to escape into my old
sunday comic supplements that says
equally terrorized by al qaeda and his
own government our hero looks over some
ancient comics pages um
that
image was not even meant
as a political cartoon it was just
trying to describe my visceral response
to what was being yanked away from me
which was uh trying to understand what
happened when these cultures collided
into a tower let's go to new york city
next call you're on there please go
ahead
uh good afternoon brian and mr
spiegelman i just have a comment and a
question first i'd just like to let you
know in response to your comment before
that you'd wish that you were spending
more time advocating world peace as
opposed to
having comics accepted as literature i
just like to let you know that 12 years
ago when i was 16 i read your book mouse
and because of it it opened my heart
i've been a social worker and i became
that in large part because of the book
and my question for you is do you feel
that there was a connection between the
way people were treating each other as
you eloquently expressed a mouse
and in the events of 9 11.
thank you very much well thank you and
thanks for that first statement
especially i must say that when i made
mouse my only goal was to make a comic
book that needed a bookmark and i didn't
think it would have any useful function
in the world uh nevertheless i'm glad
that it does i'm grateful
the only crossover between uh mao's and
this work is that for the first time in
my life i was in a situation where i
wasn't in the middle of problems of my
own making of which i've made many uh
instead i was at one of those crossroads
where world history and personal history
meet i was on that particular corner of
ground zero and as a result my father's
admonition to always keep your bags
packed took on added meaning
um i don't in any way compare uh what i
went through there as a witness to an
event of uh
whatever magnitude it was to what it
meant to survive the death camps
and
on the other hand
i feel that because of my own
predilections i find that dealing with
where my own personal life crosses over
with things that affect somebody besides
me is probably the most fertile terrain
for me to be functioning in it which is
why somewhere in the introductory essay
i talk about returning to comic strips
because disaster is my muse and it seems
like there's a lot to draw about these
days one more call and then to the
audience and then we'll wrap it up with
art spiegelman here at the strand
bookstore we go to memphis tennessee
hello hello art and brian i've really
enjoyed this and i will buy your book
it's reasonably priced so i'll buy more
than one i
really liked what you said about let's
pray for a secular nation and
liberal has become such a dirty word and
we're always supposed to be portrayed as
foaming at the mouth and i watched down
miller the other night i could barely
stand it he was fairly well frothing at
the mouth
and i think the propaganda
from the bush side is what i object more
to anything else
and the fact that you put your finger on
it people don't read as much print as
they used to so your book's going to
serve a real useful purpose and to give
you something that's an applaud i teach
holocaust studies
my teenagers in my classes brought me
mouse and wanted to use it in class and
so we did and i want to thank you for
that very much thank you um
probably the most important thing uh i
could respond to several but i know our
time is running out is this thing about
uh
uh a secular nation um my my t-shirt
which said uh pray for a secular future
uh seems to me like it touches on the
most central issues right now which is
about still doing these pages and maybe
it'll grow into being another book it
seems to me is the the war between
heaven and heck
you know uh that uh
even
the uh
evangelical christians who were uh
brought up by a caller uh may well be
served by a government that remains
strictly secular one of the most
interesting things that happened in
france in the last week was the giant
outpouring of arab support within france
for releasing the french journalists who
were held hostage this is because france
has insisted on keeping its government
completely secular in its society
completely secular it allows religion to
flourish and doesn't impose that
religion anywhere and right now what i
find the most dangerous are the uh
fundamentalist ideologues whether
they're living on the west bank
somewhere in the uh the in afghanistan
or somewhere in red zone states uh that
to me is the culture clash that has to
be dealt with most effectively in the
future for us to have a future yes sir
your name
hi my name is todd owen and i've got two
rather unrelated questions first
uh with the anniversary of 911 just five
days away how do you feel our
perspective on 9 11 is changing as each
year passes and secondly i read
somewhere that you smoke two packs a day
one and a half it's the press is full of
distortions how do you how do you feel
about the smoking is part of your public
image and what are your thoughts on
quitting
my thoughts are okay i'll take the
smoking one first because maybe it's
easier um
let's see i don't endorse smoking i'm in
fact i'm having a
uh
um
deadly battle with my daughter trying to
convince her to not be a smoker even
though that may sound insane from a
family in which there's a chain smoker
but i got addicted to this i tried to
stop for a year and a half
mouse which took 13 years could have
taken 11 and a half all i did for a year
and a half was not smoke it was my day
job
and
eventually when i went back to it i was
introduced to a uh uh
russian
a person was introduced to me as a
famous russian writer and i was
twitching because i wasn't spoken i said
i'm sorry i'm trying to not smoke at
this party and he says i used to smoke i
stopped completely i said how did you
continue writing he said i don't write i
am now doctor
and i just felt that there was no way
for me to continue in the patterns i was
in unless i was smoking even if it means
shortening my life for that and
um i certainly don't recommend it to
anybody else i just feel trapped because
i'm not allowed indoors unless i'm
breaking the law uh smoking about the
the other issues september 11th i'll
just read you the last three panels that
follow the uh cowboy boots falling on my
city of my templates which says the
towers have come to loom larger than
life but they seem to get smaller every
day happy anniversary
art spiegel we're out of time thank you
very much
again the book is in the shadows of no
towers art spiegelman available here for
14.95 and in
your bookstores other places for 19.95
we have connie dudley somewhere in the
strand area with people let us know who
you have connie